this video is sponsored by Naruto
slugfest Naruto slug this is a new
officially licensed um Naruto game for
the iOS and Android that's right you can
relive the good old naruto glory days
and play through the original story
complete with all the official voice
actors from the comfort of your own
phone this is an MMORPG that allows you
to explore the 3d open-world of Naruto
to do whatever you want
run around Konoha ninja jump around
buildings [ __ ] raid area 51 if you
want I don't give a [ __ ]
choose from four original characters
with different classes and masteries to
play them in multiple game modes from
the story driven PvE modes to the epic
PvP Guild Wars I don't have game footage
of it right now but they'll probably
look something like this let your
favorite ninjas to do battle of them
like Naruto Sasuke and not Sakura
complete with all their iconic moves
from Naruto's Rasengan to Naruto shadow
clone to Naruto Sam pre-registration has
now opened so you can click the link
below to get on the hype train and
follow your Naruto running dreams and
with that said let's get on with the
video ten gears of anime the start of
2020 marks the start of a new decade and
with that also comes the end of a decade
of anime ten years is a pretty damn long
time especially if you take a look back
at just how much has changed within that
time period so instead of doing a top X
anime over the 2010s which pretty much
everyone else has already done at this
point it would be far too much work for
a video already two months into the new
year I thought I could take this
opportunity to reflect on what happened
to anime as a whole in the past ten
years from the perspective of someone
who's been an avid fan of the medium for
the entirety of that time I've watched
as anime has slowly grown and changed
over the years we've seen a lot of good
we've seen a lot of bad we've seen a lot
of
which we've come to expect from anime so
you know what let's start with that just
how much did anime grow in the 20s
and may feels like it's on its way to
the big-boy leagues in the 2000s it felt
like this nice little industry and now
for better or worse we're in an entirely
new playing field our small little fan
run companies have either been bought
out by large international mega
corporations or other large
international mega corporations have
decided to enter the market it's kinda
jarring to see just how much the
environment has changed at the start of
the decade we saw Crenshaw completely
revolutionized the industry by bringing
in anime simulcasts and in just the 10
years since then we've seen both the
rise and fall of the Golden Age of
streaming yes it really is over though
to be fair this isn't an anime exclusive
problem there was a time when all you
needed was a Netflix account and you
would have access to pretty much
everything you wanted to and there was
also a time when you can look up the
upcoming season pick every new anime
that looked interesting to you and think
to yourself yeah these all probably all
be on crunchyroll nowadays streaming
feels like it's getting closer and
closer to that cable model we thought we
had left behind however thanks to that
Golden Age an amazing crease
accessibility meant a lot more people
got to watch it the medium is far more
popular than it ever has been validating
what we as fans always knew anime is
[ __ ] great and if more people got the
chance to see it they'd probably like
anime too and that is exactly what's
happened we've gotten to the point where
it's no longer seen as this niche weird
hobby only watched by basement dwellers
who want to see cartoon girls get [ __ ]
by tentacles not that we exactly don't
want to see that but it's still not
quite mainstream yet either the medium
has grown Lots but with that has come
growing pains problems we used to view
from afar from bigger communities like
gaming or movies have slowly pops up in
our own it feels like I can't go a week
without some new controversy coming out
or some hot take about some irrelevant
issue in my hero academia or Demon
Slayer being posted on Twitter there no
longer feels like there's this same
community homogeny around being an anime
fan man with the increased corporate
vibe the industry has right now
companies need to realize that the
honeymoon period is gone well at one
point the fandom was rooting for them to
succeed and was willing to look over a
lot of things because we were this small
tiny community that wanted to see anime
grow as it does people will and rightly
so hold them to the same standards they
hold to companies in bigger
well established industries and that
standard hasn't always been met in the
street or community you can't get away
with some of the same things you used to
and we've all needed to come to accept
that's yes anime has changed I don't
want that to come off as completely
negative though because I'd still pick
where we are now over where we started
any day of the week it's exciting to be
an anime fan now it's never been easier
to find people I can share my passion
with and most surprisingly we've also
been able to establish that yes Japan
does actually give a [ __ ] about us on
the outside we are no longer just an
afterthought we have a tangible Pole and
a voice that is heard and not to forget
the biggest effect we've seen which is
there is lots and lots of new anime now
and the quality has actually been pretty
damn good media overload was a thing and
this was no different for anime around
the middle of the decade was when I
started to feel overwhelmed about the
sheer number of anime coming out and
around the end of the decades was when I
started to feel overwhelmed about the
sheer number of good anime coming out
that's not to say the best of anime we
saw before can't match what's coming out
now but I honestly don't think we
consistently get as many good anime as
we do now or to put it in a way that's
more current I feel we are getting as
many STS shows as we ever did but on
average I think the number of a in B T
shows have increased drastically and
because of that I think my patience with
shows has just decreased so much I look
back at some of the shows I consider
pretty decent when I was first getting
into anime and now I compared to some of
the seasonal stuff coming out and I
think to myself holy [ __ ] this wouldn't
even be a CTA show compared to some of
the stuff airing today and now I'm
having trouble finding the patience to
stick with the show if it's not at least
something like a high B tier unless you
know it's that trashy show of the season
I put on for some mindless entertainment
part of the reason I found it so hard to
watch shows I've missed is because there
hardly feels like there's an opportunity
to do so and I'm just stuck in this
perpetual cycle one of the biggest
notable changes has come in the form of
viewing habits most notably the takeover
of the seasonal anime cycle as the
primary way to discover and consume new
anime this is something I've only really
seen take control within the last 10
years the first anime I ever found
myself watching weekly was leaves a
monogatari in 2012 and I
feeling was around that time at the
start of the decades where the whole
concept of seasonal anime started to
become a thing before that I was never
concerned about looking for the newer
shows I was just looking for good shows
I looked to the classics I looked to
shows that never heard of I look to
shows that had a cool looking character
someone has set as their profile picture
and gave the blind watch based on just
that there wasn't this homogeneous place
anime fans look to to find new shows and
we had the entire history of anime as
our playgrounds of course now it's far
more focused on what's hot and new like
even if you're not following the newest
seasonal shows weekly it's likely that
most of the shows you'll find yourself
watching have come out within the past
year and only occasionally goes further
back than that so what changed obviously
the rise of instant streaming platforms
allowed us access to the newest anime at
a rate we never had before no reliance
on fan subgroups to pick up a show no
waiting for episodes get served they
were out as they were airing in Japan on
a consistent schedule and importantly
that gave anime this social aspect the
seasonal cycle gave us a Ground Zero who
could gather around and discuss that was
far more tangible than the unwritten
classic anime list we had before like
even for casual Watchers who don't
follow the cycle they still would have
heard of a show like Demon Slayer when
it was out because everyone just started
talking about it instead of asking what
have you watched we started asking are
you watching to me this is the biggest
change the idea of watching anime is a
social experience was so completely
alien to me at one point I mean the
entire reason I started this YouTube
channel was because I literally had no
one I could talk about anime with and
the ironic fact is that if I had gotten
into anime within this past decades
there would be no Giga because now the
social aspect has become such a massive
part of the anime watching experience
it's never been easier to talk about it
share your thoughts in its finds
communities to discuss it and I do admit
it's very fun to be part of the
discussion so the seasonal anime cycle
will likely be the way forward to go now
for the foreseeable future which leads
us nicely into the franchise's that had
the biggest impact in the last 10 years
we've seen a handful of new titles rise
up to leave their mark on not only the
decades but a whole new generation of
anime fans but with that we also saw the
end of franchises that marked the
previous generator
the age of the big three end of this
decade with Naruto and bleach closing
out their stories and it really was an
end of an era Naruto was the anime that
got me into anime and I remember
thinking to myself back then man this is
never gonna end the big three debate is
never gonna die it's gonna be around
forever and then when it finally did it
was a sobering moment to see the very
show that got me into anime and was
there for my entire fandom was no longer
there anymore for both of these shows
she always knew the journey would end
eventually but it never felt like it
really would there was definitely a hole
that was left so of course everyone
immediately jumped on the discussion of
what was gonna replace them
it's Marga it's it's muggy right no I
know it's gonna be you toriko but for a
while nothing did and instead we got a
bunch of heavy hitters that had nothing
to do have Shonen so for a while I
thought maybe the era of generational
defining shown in jump shows was over
turns out I didn't have to wait too long
to be proven wrong
my hero academia has comfortably taken
up the mantle of one of the new era
defining shown in shows I already know
most like United States of smash' gonna
be an iconic generational memory like
how I can mention roughly taking off his
training waist and everyone still flips
their [ __ ] at the thought we shouldn't
forget though that there was never gonna
be a new big three the big three was
coined as a result of the environment
the show's created not the other way
round
and three isn't an arbitrary number that
dictates the number of shows that define
an era however with demon slayer taking
over 2019 and even black clover and
others gaining massive traction the new
era is certainly taking shape going into
the new decades I have no doubts that
these will be the shows that will define
a new generation of young anime fans
proving once again that long-running
battle Shonen will always remain king in
that aspect as for other big franchises
that I feel left their mark in the
decade it's hard to deny the almost
mainstream reach that one punch man was
able to achieve in its prime madoka
effectively changed every new magical
girl show after it until this dark messy
Edgefest completely missing the point of
what Madoka tried to do in the first
place
it's hard to imagine that at one point
Jojo was this super niche franchise that
only the most dedicated of fans would
have heard of
and now has become a staple of the anime
fandom whether you've seen it or not if
you're an anime fan you've heard of Jojo
because it's kind of become that
gatekeeper that differentiates the
completely casual Watchers to someone
who is more active and aware of the
anime community what I got treat to me
feels like it left a massive mark on the
deeper weave community because it feels
like it represents the weirdest side of
anime that we saw this decade to this
day I still can't comprehend how it
became such a huge hit but it really
opened my eyes to what felt like a new
art form I could enjoy from what I think
are the best girls of this decade to a
scene many of us weaves will look back
to and say yeah I think this was the
start of my degeneracy but for me my
personal franchise I'll remember this
decade for will have to go to attack on
Titan and this isn't because it's just a
genuinely good show that has gotten
better with each season or because of
this massive popularity that made it one
of the most prominent anime of the
decade know what cemented it for me was
one insignificant day when I was still
working an office job while having a
coffee break with some guys chatting
about what we got up to on the weekend
and the latest football scores one of my
co-workers out of nowhere turns to us
and asks if we've heard of this show
called attack on Titan I was so taken
aback that I had just heard an anime
being brought up in a normal daily
conversation that I just stood there and
stared at him in silence for a good few
seconds before asking sorry what was
that you just said oh yeah there's this
new show called attack on Titan it's
like this cartoon from Japan I think
it's like called an anime or something
but it's actually really good and it's
moments like this that will make attack
on Titan the franchise I'll remember
because for the first time in my life
anime seemed cool it was the show that
wasn't just popular for anime fans but
something that could be watched by
anyone and it's coming from a childhood
where I got bullied for liking animes
are kids to being a complete closet fan
as a teenager for fear of being mocked
and ridiculed it was a moment I never
thought would ever happen the feeling
that I didn't need to be ashamed or hide
the fact that I watch anime and as
stupid as it sounds now that was a big
deal for me today it's become a much
more accepted medium overall and looking
back it was attack on Titan that really
laid the groundwork to allow this to
happen there was one other little
franchise on a mister might have had a
small effects
because every decade has their own
trends that took over and you know we
can oftentimes look back in history and
pinpoint exactly where that trends began
from cute girls doing Q things isa KY
was the trends we are going to remember
this decade for you know it's I know it
we've all talked about it enough let's
move on cuz one other thing that seen
great change is films a lot of people
asked why I didn't mention any films in
my twenty nineteen retrospective and the
simple answer for that is because well I
just didn't get a chance to see many the
only one I did get to see was Pro mer
which was [ __ ] awesome luckily
because he got an English dub theater
release here in Japan with Japanese
subtitles yeah I don't know which to
mention I've woken up in neither the
reverse you know card dimension before
the thought of seeing anime movies in
theaters was a distant pipe dream
outside of limited Ghibli film runs but
now if a film even has a moderate amount
of hype around it there's a decent
chance it'll get a screening in a major
city at least if you live here in the
West levar don't think it's overrated
you can't deny how much the anime film
industry has your name to thank for its
current environment it broke box office
records worldwide and proved that the
wars are markets for anime films
prompting every major outlet to ask have
we found the next Miyazaki for like the
third time while we haven't reached that
same kind of community homogeny where we
can talk about the latest films and
expect everyone to have gotten a chance
to see it the fact that we even can see
an announcement for a new hype anime
film and think to ourselves well I can't
wait to see this when it comes out in
theatres is absolutely amazing to me and
I hope this is a trends that will spread
even further globally during the new
decade I mean look at all the new anime
films we have to look forward to like
how do you live by this young
up-and-coming director who knows if this
film becomes a big hit he might even
become the next Miyazaki and I think
that's everything I wanted to talk about
looking back at the last decade as a
whole if I had to sum up what happens
anime in a single sentence for me the
2010s is when anime started to grow up
its grew outside of the confounds of
hardcore fans discussing it in online
forums it grew from being a niche
industry that only catered towards one
tree it grew from being the small
distinguishable medium to a flourishing
staple of nerd culture as a whole it's
been a joy to see the journey it took
not just as a fan but someone who's been
creating anime content on YouTube for
that whole time yes if you didn't know
my first upload was in 2007 and somehow
in that time I've grown enough to become
a professional anime ah no get that word
away from me are these really the only
two options for my official job title
I'll take it I have a lot to be thankful
for in these past ten years and I never
actually thought anime would get to this
point but one thing I don't think would
have ever changed regardless of what
happens is my passion for this medium
it's been an exciting ten years of anime
and I don't know what the next ten years
are going to be like except for the fact
that I'm definitely gonna be there to
watch it
all the way hey guys giga care hope you
enjoyed that video thank you very much
again to Naruto slugfest for sponsoring
me today if any of what I showed looked
interesting to you then you can click
the link below to pre-register and get
your hands on it as soon as is out I'm
gonna be honest I'm a bit disappointed I
missed out on the beta because I really
want to try this game out like now that
I'm living in Japan I play way more
mobile games while I'm liking you on the
train and everything so uh
Naruto mobile and the more RPG let's
light up my alley so I really can't wait
to try this out and with that said thank
you very much to Robert on board Mike
elfin sisters one zero zero eight six
Elif all basil and everyone else my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month I know I literally just said
that I live in Japan now but as you can
see from my old off its background I'm
quickly this thing England again see I'm
just here for just about two weeks if
you're wondering why I released a video
on the 2010s basically and marched well
this video is actually meant to come out
like last month or earlier in the year
but due to scheduling issues it's got
delayed so hopefully wasn't too late for
you to enjoy even though it's not nearly
as topical now um so yeah that's it for
me no further updates today I've been
gigging and I will see you all next time